hey 42 here Facebook boasts over 2.2
billion loyal subjects and the average
social minion regularly shares their
opinions about their favorite cold
sandwich meats with their family and
over 300 other people that they once met
in a room somewhere their relationships
that has snapshots of their everyday and
the most intimate details of their life
they share to your Facebook Timeline is
a written and highly detailed history of
your life and as we all know a wise man
once said if you can describe your life
with one sheet of paper then you need to
turn a new page no one actually ever
said that but I couldn't find a
meaningful quote to put here so that
will have to do but just how much does
Facebook and over Internet giants like
Microsoft Google Amazon and Apple know
about you how many secret data points
have they cherry-picked from your tree
of life and what do they do with all
those sweet succulent data cherries I'll
tell you what they do they bake them
into a delicious money pie with a big
fat advert on top of it and your privacy
is the metaphorical pastry so what can
you do to stop it
from crumbling to pieces let me ask you
have you ever been searching for
something on the web such as toasters
pet food or restaurants in your area
that aren't completely terrible and then
you open up facebook and boom you see
adverts for toasters pet food and not
crap local restaurants and whatever
internet goodies you may have been
ogling
it probably happens to you all the time
and you either ignore it
chalk it up is yes another massive
coincidence or you start to get all
weird and suspicious and make a tinfoil
hat for your hamster and suspicious you
should be because the truth is that for
a long time now Facebook has been
stalking you around the entire web like
some kind of benevolent but wealthy
pedophile
yes Facebook attorneys I'm very aware
your services have a minimum age limit
please don't sue me
Facebook has always been completely free
for its users and that's because its
users you are what's being sold there's
a well-known saying that I
made or if a service is free then you
are a product you are what Facebook
sells all your lovely data Facebook
sells to advertisers the ability to
target their adverts and their products
to Facebook users in really specific
ways based on the data that Facebook has
on you say a company comes along that
makes and sells to ice cream for a price
Facebook will allow that advertiser to
advertise their delicious ice cream so
every facebook user who is a
heterosexual female between the ages of
30 and 50 who recently ended a long term
relationship and has also had a string
of other previous long-term
relationships and also happens to own
two cats and isn't lactose intolerant
and who lives in Nantucket whilst we're
at it because they can now I don't mean
to stereotype but this kind of
specificity is exactly what advertisers
are looking for and Facebook has the
ability to offer them that juicy data
unlike almost any other company on earth
because Facebook knows secrets about you
things that would make your grandma slap
you in your ruddy little face if she
ever found out there have been rumors
spreading around the internet recently
that Facebook uses people's microphones
on their smartphones and other devices
to covertly record their conversations
24/7 and then algorithms analyze that
speech data to identify what that person
may be interested in and thus show them
advertisements for it I know what you're
thinking whoa slow down there 42 you'll
be making tinfoil hats scarves and
gloves before the end of this video but
there have been thousands of reports
across the web and even videos of people
talking about something out loud in
front of their phone for example
discussing their holiday plans to France
and then they log into Facebook later
and boom they see ads for villas in
France so what's the deal here is there
any truth to this is Facebook a naughty
Nancy spying on us through our phones
microphones the reassuringly
disappointing reality is that the
expense resources and enormous process
power required to record perform vocal
recognition on and run an algorithm on
billions of audio feeds 24 hours a day
is with current technology completely
impossible even with the resources of
all the big tech companies combined so
the likelihood that Facebook or any
other tech giant is using your
microphone to spy on you is really
really small and X Facebook employees
have said that it's just not technically
or legally possible for Facebook to do
that but the scary truth and why I'm
fairly comforted that Facebook aren't
recording us is that they don't need to
seriously they wouldn't actually gain
and the potential risks are enormous and
why wouldn't they gain anything because
they can already find out everything
they need to know about you without
listening to a single one of your
conversations
Facebook's algorithms are so
sophisticated and their data harvesting
net is so unfathomably wide that they
can already build a complete history of
your life a comprehensive profile of
your likes dislikes where you've been
where you're likely to go and what
you're likely to purchase just solely
based on your online activity and now
you're stuck there wishing you hadn't
shopped online for avocados slices for
four hours on Sunday but what you might
not know about Facebook's data
harvesting net is just how wide those
greedy data fishermen spread it
everything you do on Facebook itself
whether through the website or its app
is collected and stored private messages
status updates likes dislikes comments
and location data but it doesn't stop at
the Facebook car what have I told you
that Facebook and many other advertising
companies follow you around the entire
internet tracking every website you
visit and every interaction
you know those like and share buttons
that you see on 99% of websites that no
one uses ever and all those sites that
use login with Facebook
well for web developer to put these
features into a web page they have to
make a pact to a face book written in
code and blood they will have to include
a line of JavaScript tracking code on
their website some refer to it as a
Facebook pixel to make it sound or cute
and innocent when the visitor loads a
website that contains the Facebook pixel
and to be clear that is close to every
webpage you visit on a daily basis ever
the pixel lets facebook know that you
visited that webpage it sends back a
packet of data about yourself and your
location when you log into Facebook it
places a file called a cookie on your
computer or mobile device now most
cookies go all bad and rotten and
eventually remove themselves from your
computer after 30 days or so but these
cookies are baked with whatever
plutonium-based preservative that
McDonald's puts into they're not burgers
they never expire and unless you find
this not so delicious radioactive cookie
yourself and delete it it will sit on
your device forever
now every time you visit a website that
isn't Facebook the cookie alerts the
Facebook code that is most likely in
that website in the form of a like or
share button or login with Facebook
integration the cookie contains a unique
code which identifies your Facebook
account so the website then reports back
to Facebook behind the scenes it sends
your IP address your location the
browser and device you're using plus
other information like a delicious data
bento box
sent straight to Facebook that contains
bits of you Facebook uses all this data
to build a detailed profile about you
including all the web sites that you
visit and yes even the ones that you
don't want them to know about you sicko
using all this data Facebook can
accurately work out what you're
interested in and most importantly
what's you're likely to spend your money
on this data isn't sold but
is leased to advertisers who wish to
targets their products to a very
specific audience
Facebook's net is wide - they don't just
use these data collection techniques
through Facebook platform and the
developer network the data is also
collected through their web of companies
such as Instagram whatsapp and of course
Facebook messenger the three
cornerstones of a moronic social diet
all the data is funneled into the same
algorithm to build the most complete
possible profile on you because today
now more than ever before knowledge is
power and data is money so invasive is
Facebook's tracking that they seriously
annoyed the country of Belgium and if
there's one thing you don't want to do
its make enemies with the country that
gave the world chips waffles and more
beers than you can shake and no not in
2016 a Belgian court attempted to sue
Facebook for shadow tracking its users
across the web the Belgian Court
strongly disagreed with how Facebook
secretly follows their citizens down
every dark alleyway of the internet
wearing the long blue trench coat
wielding those cold reptilian azúcar
Berg eyes that say we will take your
data and you will enjoy it and they
argue that Facebook doesn't do enough to
make their users aware when and on what
sites they are being tracked and their
data is being harvested in a dragnet
style and all citizens are just
defenseless little tuna fish flopping
from one useless web page to the next it
was also discovered that Facebook was
also tracking users that have never even
visited Facebook or don't have a
Facebook account using their social
sharing plugins that are on every web
site worth more than a pound Facebook
allegedly logs the IP address the pages
they visit and over information of
website visitors regardless if they have
a Facebook account even though these
users have never agreed to a Facebook
privacy policy all their terms and
conditions which we've all read
we thus this data is being collected
illegally according to the belgian cause
so stoked up on delicious premium beers
the belgian court went full-on beast
mode against facebook saying that until
facebook changes its behavior and stops
tracking its users around the web that
it would have to pay a fine of two
hundred and fifty thousand euro a day
but Facebook is wealthier than Pablo
Escobar's left forum according to
estimated revenue figures it takes
Facebook just twenty-one minutes to make
two hundred and fifty thousand euro yet
it was still enough of a threat to make
Zuckerberg empty face have an actual
expression and he set his best lawyers
on the Belgians like some kind of
high-stakes Pokemon battle
initially Facebook atchoo won the battle
on a technical clause but fast forward a
couple of years until well now and the
Belgians hit back with a new lawsuit due
to recent changes in EU law that means
any EU country can sue any company that
operates or sell services within any
other European country but this time
those Belgian beauties won
the court deems that by anonymously
following people around the internet and
collecting data on them that Facebook
had contravenes EU privacy laws Facebook
was ordered to destroy all unlawfully
collected data which is about as easy as
cleaning your disgusting internet
history in internet bloody Explorer and
they were ordered to stop the practice
immediately or pay one hundred million
dollars in fines but it's not just
Facebook that knows your preferred color
of swimwear for many years now Apple has
been building undercover location and ad
tracking technology right into their
operating systems Apple uses what they
call an ID FA a unique identifier that
your iPhone sends back to Apple every
time you visit a website download an app
or just open an app Apple shares this ID
FA data with app developers and
advertisers so that they can better
target their ads towards you
when all Apple devices also track your
GPS location data and build a detailed
private map of exactly where you've been
down to specific addresses and
businesses
concretely winning stalker of the Year
award Google also does this on both iOS
and Android devices you can actually see
a map of exactly where you went and the
path you took on any given date if you
haven't already take a look afterwards
it will be the creepiest thing you've
seen in 36 minutes all this covert data
collecting makes one thing should we be
ok with allowing our personal
information to be harvested like meat
and sold to the highest bidder like a
cheap prostitute we all enjoy the many
benefits of social networks apps free
email and countless other services where
we the consumer are the product but when
all these tech companies are collecting
a permanent and detailed databank of
your life a digital version of your
personality should we be ok with that
that's really something that you need to
decide for yourself but when our data is
the product that generates revenue if we
didn't allow companies to harvest it
then there would be no service simple as
that
your great aunt Mavis will never see
that sultry selfie that you posted from
the toilet of some cheap bar last Friday
night and how utterly tragic would that
be it's our personal data that allows
companies like Facebook and Google to
exist in today's world where data is
king but it only seems fair that we
should know when and how our data is
being collected doesn't it you're all
very aware by now of the recent
Cambridge analytical scandal our data
was harvested from Facebook by data
scientists in huge quantities without
our knowledge or direct consent and then
the data was analyzed to target
political attack ads attles online and
put a watermelon in the White House the
whole thing has blown up into a scandal
so big it would make Nixon jealous and
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg was made to
testify in court over the whole thing
and even worse smile huh but what makes
Cambridge analytic is so utterly
scandalous is that for every user who
took the quiz that harvested that uses
data it also spread into their network
of friends like a virus and harvested
their data too without their consent
resulting in the personal data being
stolen from 87 million Facebook profiles
in total Facebook has been on the
defense ever since whilst they're being
puddle whipped from all sides but to rub
salt into their wounds they are now
under pressure from a new European law
that aims to change the way data is
collected for good it's no coincidence
that this video was released today
because tomorrow a new law several years
in the making
comes into effect across the whole of
Europe it's called gdpr
or general data protection regulation
and it's the biggest slap in the face to
companies that wish to anonymously
harvest our data since sliced litigation
GDP our basically means that companies
like Facebook and hundreds of thousands
of others that wish to access our data
have to be really transparent and
upfront about when and how they are
getting that data and importantly
exactly what they plan to do with it
they have to inform us in plain English
- not legal soup if you do still use
Facebook then you may have noticed is
pop up appearing recently upon logging
in that's because the European Court has
forced them to do so under the GDP our
GDP are also gives European citizens the
right to write to any company that has
collected their data and ask them to
delete it permanently unbelievably up
until now this hasn't actually been
possible with most companies you see the
way data storage solutions such as SQL
work means it's so much easier for the
company to just tick a box that hides
your data from the public instead of
actually deleting it like you asked them
to so when you deactivate or delete your
Facebook account or any other online
it and all the data surrounding it still
exists it's just hidden but still on
Facebook servers but such companies can
still access that data at any time
unfortunately GDP are only affects
European citizens or any business based
in Europe but hold on the Servius of tax
avoiders out there will know that to
avoid billions of pounds of tax each
year Facebook is technically
headquartered in Ireland yes they
exploit a huge legal tax loophole called
a double irish sandwich to avoid paying
corporation tax in all the countries
that they operate in which is basically
all of the countries so the totally
American mega corporation Facebook is on
paper an Irish company but shouldn't
this mean that Facebook has to abide by
the GDP are for all its users across the
globe because technically it's
headquartered in Europe ideally yes but
instead Facebook sat in a room in
Ireland and said ho by guinness party
you're gonna love this then they did a
massive legal magic trick effectively
excluding 1.5 billion of their users who
don't live in europe from being affected
by the gdp are whilst using facebook
services and if you want me to explain
exactly how they did that then i'm going
to need about five more pints of
Guinness and a law degree to pass that
bar what to put it simply Facebook have
basically said if you don't live in
Europe then you don't have the right to
control your own personal data at the
end of the day your data is more
important than you probably give it
credit for when some faceless
conglomerate knows your most intimate
secrets and holds more information about
you than your own mother you should be
worried because that gives them enormous
power over you and who knows what the
future holds for all of us your personal
data can be used to manipulate you
brainwash you and sell you plastic
freaking vegetable choppers there's six
carbon steel blades and nobody wants
that there are lots of ways you can
still use these free online services
whilst keeping a firm grasp on your data
and online security
but one of the best ways is to use a
virtual private network a VPN
that's why I use Nord VPN every time I
connect to the internet on every device
I own so I can stay totally private
online not VPN have kindly sponsored
this video hopefully by now you guys
know that I only promote products that I
truly believe it and Nord VPN is a
product that I believe in so strongly
that I have been using their VPN
personally every day since I discovered
Nord VPN over a year ago really Nord VPN
has an automatic kill switch
super simple browser extensions and it
even blocks ads for you know VPN has an
incredible 4319 service to choose from
all over the globe so you can be
anywhere you want Nord VPN is super fast
and it has no impact on your internet
speed whilst using it it really doesn't
they have 24/7 customer support
they never log any of your data because
they are based outside of the EU and the
US and that's really important when
choosing a VPN you can use unlimited
bandwidth and they use double layer data
encryption for total anonymity online
the best part
it's incredible value for money I firmly
believe that every Internet user should
use a VPN even if it's just for peace of
mind and knowing that your data and
internet browsing activity is safe and
there is no VPN better than Nord VPN I
can personally vouch for that
click the link in a description to sign
up to get your Nord VPN account now and
secure yourself online once and for all
you won't regret it thanks for watching
if this video made you feel all warm and
tingly inside then please click here to
support me on patreon so you can see
more of them also don't forget to check
out Noor VPN by using the link in the
description it's such a great service